this is a production of cornell
university
yep thanks everybody for joining uh this
is the 14th episode of the cornell turf
show this year our third season
uh today's guest is a guest we had on on
our first season dr
cal bigelow of purdue uh you may know
him dr big on twitter you can follow him
there
we'll get to a conversation later with
cal i'm sure we'll talk about uh
irrigation turf grass nutrition we've
talked about growth rates in the past of
lawn turf uh so frank will have some
surprises there i'm sure
uh but as always frank i'll let you get
us started today and see what's going on
in the um
the weather world here let me get the
right page uh and we've got some
curveballs i think for dr bigelow day we
want to keep him on his toes you know
he's got those young people that he's
training so uh thank everybody for
joining us uh welcome whether you're
live or um on the podcast or watching
the video
uh this is the fastest 30 minutes in
turf our lawn and grounds edition got
this great picture from somewhere out
west where these sticks of artificial
corn are sticking up in a dandelion i
think that's ohio is it ohio okay right
so you must have seen this it is it must
i know it's in the midwest somewhere so
that's uh it's i i was struck by uh i
love uh lawn art and things out in the
landscape but this poor guy
tweeted this out uh after 15 years
i wonder if there were signs that this
thing was failing but you gotta you know
here's what i love you gotta love oh
wait a second let me get the pen
you gotta love the golf ball on the
height adjuster right right making it
effective right you got to like that
ingenuity of this guy all right carl
what's the start of the day today i
can't wait to hear what this is
yeah so uh it used to be a show frank i
think it was on espn it was pros versus
joe's and it was pro athletes versus
just kind of every guy everyday guys off
the street uh and looked at some uh some
data here out of ohio state
and they compared basically three lawn
uh lawn care regiments they looked at
lawns that were maintained by
landscaping professionals
diyers do-it-yourselfers who would go
and follow
kind of a retail brand
program for their lawn
and then kind of lazy homeowners who
just mow no other inputs just mowing and
they looked at stuff like wheat invasion
and turf grass quality
and for those who can see up in the top
right
turf grass quality no surprise was
highest with the professional
management program
and significantly lower with both the
diy-ers and the no input program
but interestingly there was no
difference between the the diy-ers who
had who were
applying fertilizer herbicides and the
no input folks and actually you could
also see another graph down there on the
bottom uh more weed incidents of course
with the the di the no input folks but
also diy-ers actually had more uh ground
ivy
about the same broadleaf planting as uh
the no input one so
we see the pros win uh not surprisingly
the pros win uh but also the lazy joe's
win so it you know this was back in the
mid 2000's maybe our our diy lawn owners
weren't weren't uh as good at
maintaining their lawns back then maybe
they're better now um but but we saw
back then certainly that if you if you
were going to maintain it yourself just
mow it through there there's no reason
to
to apply so just an interesting study
and again this is in ohio but
some interesting uh an interesting look
yeah and i know carl you you do a fair
amount yourself uh as the lazy joe uh no
input although you are ramping it up a
little bit with the kid uh and a dog
right
a dog will put a dent in your plans
really quick then then it's hard to uh
maintain turf cover with a terrier
running around so that's what i was
going to say does no input
include uh you know ravaged by dogs and
kids
yeah that's that's a good question
they'll have to take that data next time
dogs per household okay all right well
let's get to the roller coaster that is
the weather uh and i know kale's been
dealing with this out in the midwest as
well you can see the up and down and
we're getting close to highs one week
and close to lows
uh record highs one week record lows the
next week so this fluctuating up and
down cal i just love that you keep
taking these same pictures from the same
place where is this on the purdue campus
so that is the purdue mall that's the
central focal point uh they're right in
the center of campus and you know sort
of intersection of lots of things so
it's
multi-purpose and it gives me uh
probably a little bit like you if you're
actually paying attention you know i
like to go back at the end of the year
and just kind of see how things have
you know ups and downs it's good to know
right right and and early on you've had
this ups and downs right you you you
know warmed up out of the gate got going
obviously you already had traffic on it
i guess everybody's glad it wasn't the
18th on the 11th right when all the
tents were out there but right so that
was that was spring fest right that was
the weekend of spring fest um
and the the the turf bug bowl or the bug
bowl that they have you know good
holidays bug bowl is part of that
cricket's fitting and everything so
well
this
okay i'm gonna leave that there kale and
i'm gonna go with science here on the
fall spring right uh one of the things
that we're starting to see
uh is this uh release of dormancy and
then uh subsequent cold temperatures
release of dormancy
and subsequent cold temperatures and i'm
sure you're aware that the folks in
minnesota have been playing around with
this particularly with the increase in
tall fescue
that's getting used up there and i know
cal you've been playing around quite a
bit more with tall fescue and certainly
water use and mowing and nutrition but
from this perspective the fall spring on
the tall fescue let me ask you right out
of the gate
are you seeing these fluctuating
temperatures in the spring
uh cause problems to some of these two
tall fescue i mean obviously you
probably got some kentucky bluegrass
there a little bit too but way more tall
fescue are you seeing this fluctuating
temperature impact on any of your
variety trials for example
it's it's pretty mixed i think from year
to year it's not very consistent but um
there have been times in recent years
that for whatever reason
we've had some things that have been
planted the previous fall and you sort
of get that roller coaster and there's
there's a few things that uh even from
trials that were planted last year uh
that things are not greening up like we
hoped
so there is a potential impact there
okay and you're talking about new
establishments not mature establishments
yeah i think once you get past that
first year you're probably in the clear
but i think the things that were
established in
even in september of last year we've
seen some potential issues this year
with
just this past week going out and
looking at some you know some green up
ratings on some trials we planted last
year
uh that there's some stuff i don't know
if it's going to make it and that's a
little concerning that's that's very an
end oh boy that's always those are
always fun all right let's get to the
weather a little bit obviously uh it was
a little cooler than normal sort of to
the east uh new england and a slightly
warmer than normal with buffalo uh
winning the day the western new york
area winning the day for warmer than
normal uh just about two four to six
degrees and of course growing degree
great growing degree day accumulation
base 50 anyway all of them no matter
whether it's 22 50 55 32 whatever
they're accumulating and obviously the
50 base uh growing degree days are not
accumulating that rapidly uh over the
last week now the outlook is uh probably
mostly below average now when you look
at the six to ten day but in the
immediate time frame you're seeing very
again very low accumulation of degree
days even really maxing out in the metro
new york area in the 30 to 40 range so
we're still not accumulating them uh
this far north uh as much as they are
obviously as you get further south we're
still about looks like about a week to
two weeks behind normal about three
weeks behind last year which i thought
was interesting uh from our climate
person yesterday so um it's also been
one of the first times i can remember
we've been starting to dry so rainfall
has been fairly light
across the region and
what is starting to happen is as the sun
gets higher in the sky we're starting to
get more drying right so quite a bit
more of apple transpiration drying out
the system so that you know a half an
inch of rain um may not always uh last
you as long as the sun starts to come up
in the sky so you should start to see
the first signs
particularly on poor soils soils that
don't hold a lot of water are very
compacted you should start to see signs
of a little bit of stress in those areas
where soils are not good and the turf is
weak going in now the forecast uh is
again giving you that indication that
it's going to be slightly nor you know
slightly dry uh we're not going to see
an increase in soil moisture but it
looks like long term 6 to 10 day anyway
that we're in for a little bit more
moisture
across the northeastern u.s now
when you get into the soil this soils
have tracked very similarly to the
roller coaster of the air temperatures
right so you can look at our highest
elevations and you can be in the 40s and
you go to the metropolitan new york area
you might even be starting to creep into
the upper 50s down into atlantic city
you might even get into the 60s at the
2-inch depth but we're also heading into
another cold spell over the next few
days so you'll want to track this now if
you're tracking soil temperature for
different reasons one of the primary
reasons we do in the lawn environment i
think uh where we're not spraying
fungicides is monitoring for crab grass
germination right stilt grass as we've
talked about before matt elmore at
rutgers made us aware it's already up
crab grass will be the next one in line
not far behind that will be goose grass
right so we're going to start tracking
crabgrass and gru's grass
emergence and i haven't heard
yet of too much emergence in the
northeast yet the phenological
indicators are certainly suggesting from
a forsythia perspective that crabgrass
would be germinating but when you look
at the prediction of crabgrass
germination using these base 50 degree
day models and kale was probably around
uh
i don't think was i don't know did peter
know do any of this stuff did he do he
did crabgrass prediction with fedonza
didn't he care were you there
yeah he did that was um that was before
me but so that would have been early 90s
yeah i forget how young you are still
cal you're still still still young
compared to myself and fedonza he might
even be older than medial frisky fairy
ring we had him on
was it last week carl we had mike on
he's he's sipping cappuccinos in italy i
know who's got a better gig than that
guy all right so crabgrass is
germinating right slow but sure and you
can see that over the next several days
we're not going to see very much so just
a reminder for everybody that's running
out to do their pre-emergent control
right
you are from right now looking at a 14
to 16 week season for crabgrass control
right i think that's pretty much what
we're going to see for how much
prevention you're going to need more so
uh for goose grass right yeah you're
going to need longer control for goose
grass cruise grass germinating in in mid
august can still produce viable seed uh
before the end of the year so
pre-emergent weed control when you look
at this chart you can see everybody's
pretty good in the four to six weeks
range but once you get into um larger
longer periods of time where you want 12
to 15 weeks right now ben salad is not
as good uh team is not as good right
benefit triflurally you want to watch
out hopefully you're not using too many
of those products that you're going with
the more longer lasting products now the
other thing you'll notice is you get a
little bit of annual bluegrass
suppression you get a little bit of
broadleaf
weed suppression as well but the key to
this is
keeping the barrier in place right the
pre-emergent barrier in place
during that spring you know length of
the season now you know as the earth is
warming it's getting harder and harder
to control these weeds there's new ones
evading these practices right still
grass is coming up earlier goose grass
coming up later goose grass avoids
diethiopir we don't use as much much ron
star up here so we're starting to get uh
goose grass problems all of these things
conspire to want to make sure you can
get a really good timing of these
pre-emergent products now we also know
in the commercial lawn and landscape
institutional grounds business it's not
always easy to to do uh ideal timing
right to get it down because you got to
get the work done within the raindrops
uh within the the driving within the
all the other things you have to do in
the spring getting these things down is
not always easy to do so keep in mind
being strategic uh monitoring when they
could be germinating and even if you
wait till you see a little germination
if you're to use dimension especially if
you're going to liquid apply it you can
knock back some of those early posts
those early stage
crab grass plants and still get good
pre-emergent control now the other thing
that's happening in the lawns in the
northeast is they're really starting to
flower right now right and when you look
at this relative flowering time you know
i don't know how much i love this
particular graph but it is a good at
least partial indicator that there are
weeds in flour right and one of the
things that's important about that is if
you're going out with your grub control
if you're going out with your herbicide
applications and you're trying to marry
this idea of you know of pollinator lawn
with i don't want grubs or a pollinator
lawn with i still want to spray these
weeds out that gets really tricky when
you get into these situations but the
rule of thumb is simply if you're going
to apply any pesticide or any product to
a lawn
be sure to remove those flowers if the
lawn has flowers in it be sure to remove
them prior to any application now if
you're more interested in controlling
them we certainly i know purdue has a
good one we've got one lots of good weed
id grass id guides out there um very
simple ways to get these things
identified kale this a picture you
tweeted earlier uh about dandelion
control now this is my next question for
you you know this model for dandelion
control came out of purdue i think
before even you and i were born back in
the throssell riker days when you know
before dirt was invented uh back in
purdue uh do you still use this is this
something that your industry uses and in
your sense does it work for more than
just dandelions
you know that that's a that's a good
question i don't know how widely it's
adopted
uh i would say that some of them were
astute lawn care operators are probably
paying a little bit of attention to this
and you know there certainly are some
price points on these products on the
shelves i think you know
one is almost probably twice as much as
the other uh you know out our way there
are still a number of folks that are uh
dealing with the um you know the ground
ivies and the wild pilots and still
chasing that and that maybe is coming
into some of this conversation you know
as far as esther's versus amines
uh but you know
beyond you know having having that
conversation and taking it to the point
that you're looking at it on this basis
i think it's probably pretty limited
unless it's somebody that's really got
their programs dialed in or has a
specific need because they're having you
know a history of a problem
and of course this was developed because
we knew people weren't making
applications in the fall and they wanted
to figure out a way to at least give
them some target in the spring so i do
think you're right i think what we talk
about all the time with any of these
models is they're really good reference
points i mean i like looking at them to
just say well this thing says i'm you
know if i'm in central new york i i'm
still
two weeks away from having to apply
based on this at the same time uh what i
see in the field might indicate maybe
it's time for me to go based on my
previous experience now when we start to
talk about
weeds in the lawn uh we've been having
some very interesting conversations over
the last couple of weeks with our
extension staff as no mo may has come
around
and
changing the name of weeds to incidental
flowering plants i think that's uh going
to get a lot of people interested and of
course the university of minnesota and i
know kale you guys have played around
with this as well at purdue looking at
different ways of thinking about uh
vegetation that's closely cut or maybe
allowed to go to a meadow
and i think uh we've seen just this
morning this what's got me going uh just
this morning the bbc put out a very
interesting article here on why lawns
may have had their day and i would say
these things are pretty much on time
this is a time when uh google analytics
indicates people are searching things
for lawns and soils weeds and seed so we
know that there with the data we collect
on how people search this is a popular
time and so people who have uh media
outlets like to write these things this
happens to be i actually like this one
and this one was really interesting as
well not maybe as applicable to us here
in the northeast because it seems like
we can't shut the darn water off but cal
i know that you have very much gotten
more involved in this thing so as we
start to think about
various types of lawn we've been trying
to we've been efforting to get professor
bill miller here uh to talk about his uh
lawn plantings of these bulbs now
daffodil is not a good example because
it's not really a a pollinator
uh bulb but there certainly are many
pollinator-friendly bulbs this is
interestingly he's testing different
densities this is about five per square
foot and you can see these different
densities of these little daffodils that
he's planting so you've got the high
density all the way down to the low
density but what i'm
suggesting is we're beginning to think
about the lawn differently but at the
same time cal and this is where you come
in brother um you know ntep trials this
is some of kevin frank's
spring kentucky bluegrass greening up i
know you uh do this a lot uh out at west
lafayette and and so as we bring you in
let me start with that question kale
when you think about that early spring
stuff now obviously early spring for you
might even be march and february
compared to a little later for us up
here
what are you thinking about what kinds
of
you know can you say with any confidence
a bluegrass greens up better than a tall
fescue greens up better than a rye grass
or is it varietal differences that
uh a good tall fescue can be as good as
a good bluegrass for spring green up i'm
really interested in that particular
stuff because i know you've taken tons
of data on this just some general
thoughts on what yeah so
just you know some general thoughts from
you know my my time here with you know a
couple iterations of you know all the
species at this point
um i think the thing that we we
definitely will see is you know if you
had to rank those
in and using a broad brush here
perennial rye grass is usually first out
of the gate okay but you know that can
be good and bad because we can also go
back to the whole uh you know crown
hydration issues and you could
potentially lose some rye grasses right
i mean any blue grass and rye grass
those tend to be the ones that start
taking up water first
so from a you know consumer side of
things and retail mixes i
it starts to create a little bit of a
compelling case of why you know our
friends are putting those into those rye
grasses into the retail mixes and i
think that ban for the rye grass is
probably pretty narrow there's some
varietal differences right
among the tall fescues i'm seeing some
that are a little bit better in terms of
that spring green up but still they're
they're a step behind the rye grasses
and then with the blue grasses that band
is pretty wide you know we've got
whatever we just rated blue grasses
yesterday and there's 90 in the most
recent trial that's about to expire
we'll be getting another one here in
about two years but within those
you know those midnight types you know
that are traditionally found in a lot of
seed mixtures those still are the
laggards right i mean those are the ones
that they're going to do what they're
going to do when they're going to do it
they're almost as bad as oyster grass
but there are some other ones
that do come out of the gate pretty fast
as far as spring green up but if you if
spring green up was really important to
you and bluegrass was really important
to you i would do my homework if you
wanted early color and i think of our
friends that are managing major league
baseball parks right i mean they first
week of april you know if you're in
toledo or you know wherever it is even
in chicago
you know unless you've got grow blankets
or something else some of those
bluegrasses might just lay there so yeah
and and you know part of my motivation
for for sort of approaching it this way
is
when we think about lawn alternatives
and people think about what they don't
like about lawns at the end of the day
what almost everybody is looking for is
some like in behind me and behind you
and behind car something that's
uniformly green uh and i think like carl
said in the pros versus joe section that
most people if they cut it and when they
cut it from the curb it looks like uh if
they can stripe it even more so if they
can stripe it i don't think most people
care if it's green and i worry sometimes
we're you know even you know grounds
operations want to get good for
graduation or get good for a particular
event they'll put nitrogen they'll put
iron uh have you seen any and i'm trying
to avoid that maybe iron's okay but i
don't want to put nitrogen on early what
do you guys do do you see your lawn care
industry going out and making those
early season applications to get it down
and get it done because it works that
way or are you
seeing maybe we're getting better
varieties greening up and not needing as
much much input
i think we've got to change that
culturally right i think i think that
there's still you know
a lot of uh pros joe's or chucks and
trucks that are they're still
programmatic um and maybe are not as as
careful with those with those early
season nitrogen applications and that
that concerns me and i i think maybe
that the tune will change this year
based on nitrogen prices you know
compared to what they were a year or two
years ago these folks maybe are going
back to their accountants and taking a
little closer look at that but
those early season nitrogen applications
you know if you've got a midnight
kentucky bluegrass like i said it's
going to do what it's going to do when
it's going to do it and it's all based
on soil temperature and going out there
and juicing it with a half a pound and
coming back another two weeks with
another half a pound
that's that's ill-advised from my
standpoint because then you get the
grass factory right when it does green
up
it's a mowing situation and then it's
clippings and it's
it's not pleasant right so you know as
we as we start to wrap up already you
know we weren't lying it was the fastest
30 minutes as we start to wrap up um
i know you've played around with lawn
alternatives i'm not going to ask any
specifics i mean
do you think we're going to get any
traction we're going to get these crappy
articles lawns are bad what is your
sense of traction that any long
alternative could potentially get
like close
in our lifetime something will happen
in our lifetime something will happen
and one of the things that was
compelling from one of the studies that
kevin morris had put together i think it
was 2015 2016 it was that low
maintenance one and we had included a
yarrow in there and the yarrow was
actually very interesting and i know
that paul johnson and utah had some
interesting results at six inches of
rain a year and
you know is is that would take some
tweaking to include that in there but
under dry dry conditions like you're
experiencing the northeast and we're
getting more in the midwest where you're
getting these dry summers
if we got to ratchet off the water maybe
we need some other things but i do think
some alternatives are coming
i i agree and you know tom cook talks a
lot about yarrow in his uh original
conceptualizing the eco lawn like what
was the what's the cl like if you're a
joe or a chuck in a truck like carl was
saying you guys are saying and all
you're doing is mowing what is the
climax vegetation in a lawn in your
ecoregion right what is the mix of
plants that will establish themselves
now i'll say this the only thing i tell
people it's like look you know what i
want it's no problem with me you want
weeds it's no problem with me you don't
want annual weeds
i don't want bare grounds i want
something that stabilizes the soil right
you want something to stabilize that
soil that's right and and you know
seeding in different varieties or even
putting in flowering plants you know
doug was sold that was here a couple of
weeks ago we talked about uh no mo may
and he's like no that's bad mo hi may
june july that way maybe if there's
flowers in there they'll survive
underneath it's not just a one month
thing it's a many month thing
uh clover is the easy one do you like
clover in your mixes have you guys has
kevin and the ntep guys thought more
about playing around with these mixtures
in an end type situation
we in that one study i just mentioned
there were a few of those for whatever
reason at our site you know whether it
was some winter kill or some other
pathogen that maybe came in the clover
populations
dissipated more than i expected you know
when you try it's like any weed when you
try and cultivate the weed it doesn't
want to do it and you know it's exactly
right um the one plant that's been kind
of compelling to me
um has been the wild violet
you know wild violet uh in some of the
mature lawns around our our
our city here you know it never gets
very tall right and it flowers for a
little while and then you kind of it
kind of disappears and you know that
that that early spring interest is of of
of note i don't know what it does in
terms of the the pollinators and
everything but um that maybe would be
something that has some potential well
and it's and it's a bear to control it's
not it's like you got to like put the
the jug a triclopia on it to control
right
so listen carl we're at the witching
hour here uh
questions or comments
yeah so i got an overall comment if if
i'm looking at this like uh like a
landscaper right and you guys are
telling me hey we gotta mow less we
gotta apply less and and i've got a
business model i gotta keep
um i wonder if either of you guys have
seen something like uh an ipm program
offering from a landscaper where maybe
there it's instead of okay
four applications per year and we're
gonna mow every two weeks maybe they pay
they offer
okay pay us the same exact rate or maybe
even extra and we're gonna do more
scouting we're going to do more a
targeted application approach we're
going to take a soil test to see if you
need any of these other nutrients we're
going to look at growth rate and if you
have a lawn that grows less and it's not
irrigated
okay we're not going to mow it as much
because that's unnecessarily uh
releasing any of these businesses you
guys seen these progressive ipm lawn
businesses popping up
um
i don't i
i think it's it's a consumer education
piece right
and i think that's where it breaks down
i think there's genuine interest from
some some savvy
you know uh individuals that are looking
are forward thinking with where lawn
care could go and especially talking to
these millennials and you know what they
want out of their lawn
i think that that has some potential but
it still just breaks down
yeah it breaks out i think it breaks
down economically people don't want to
pay for somebody to have to drive out
there all the time i've seen one company
do it but it's a landscape management
it's not just a lawn it typically
involves the entire landscape and
there's ornamental plants that scouting
and spot treating uh can also make some
sense but yeah i think it's a tough
model and i mean
i mean right now the model is i get paid
when i apply i get paid when i mow yeah
right that's exactly right so all right
carl
cal so great to have you pal and i love
our text chats with that crew yeah
what a blast that is thanks for taking
the time carl get us out
yep thanks everyone for joining uh we'll
see you next week for a golf show
and a sports show so we're looking to
secure guests but we'll see you guys
next week take care thanks kale
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu